à dijon s'est ouvert aujourd'hui le
procès en appel de chant pierre murat en
première instance l'an dernier il avait
été condamné à 20 ans de prison pour le
meurtre de christelle mairi state en
1986 au creusot trente ans après les
faits jean pierre murat continue à
clamer son innocence compte rendu de
pauline ringenbach et christophe
gaillard je vous le redis aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas moi qui tu es et christelle
après une heure et demie
d'interrogatoire gentil remuera un peu
agacé a de nouveau clamé son innocence
devant la cour affirmant très clairement
ne pas connaître
christelle mairi et ne l'avoir jamais
rencontré à l'époque des faits un jour
il connaît un jour y connaît pas un jour
il a dit ça c'est de c'est le juge qui
ment c'est le policier qui ment c'est la
cour qui a rajouté des choses enfin
c'est tout juste pas possible
donc je crois que en tout cas c'est
plutôt pour lui que ça pose problème
c'est à dire que du coup l'absence de
crédibilité de ces déclarations font que
ses dénégations d'humeur de christelle
ne rencontre pas beaucoup d'échos
l'accusé pourtant très attentif aux
débats accumulé confusion contradictions
et incohérences dans ses déclarations
traitant les différents témoins de
menteur je crois que monsieur murat est
en proie à un véritable stress qui peut
se comprendre puisque ce procès c'est le
procès de la dernière chance est
aujourd'hui ce qui peut expliquer
effectivement les confusions d'autant
que nous sommes rentrés dans le vif du
sujet très rapidement en abordant dès
cette matinée tous les éléments à charge
qui ont pu être retenues contre monsieur
murat christelle mairi a été sauvagement
tué de 31 coups de couteau ce 18
décembre 1986 le rapport d'autopsié a
été lu par la présidente à la cour des
précisions des détails difficile à
entendre pour la famille de la victime
de revivre ça on imagine en prennent un
sens autrement les jasper
un peu jeune on va dire c'est difficile
demain lors du deuxième jour d'audience
d'autres experts seront entendus et ce
seront les différents enquêteurs qui ont
travaillé sur cette affaire pendant 30
ans qui se succéderont à la barre
et l'on retrouve pauline ringenbach en
direct de la cour d'appel bonsoir
pauline cette journée a donc été
particulièrement dense
oui eric est effectivement l'accusé n'a
donc pas été épargné par les questions
lors de cette première journée
d'audience pendant plus de deux heures
la présidente lui a posé énormément de
questions
et comme je viens de vous l'indiquer
jean pierre murat a été plutôt
déstabiliser l'homme justifie notamment
son obsession pour ce meurtre par une
prise excessive à l'époque de drogue et
d'alcool alors nous verrons demain
comment jean pierre murat se comportent
et réagit face aux enquêteurs qui ont
donc mené les investigations qui ont
abouti finalement à son arrestation
seulement en 2011 jean pierre murat qui
est aujourd'hui âgé de 48 ans en cours
tout de même 30 ans de réclusion
criminelle
merci paul noël de bach